we previously discussed the 11 year old
girl in uvalde texas who
uh testified to congress about her
experiences watching her friend and her
teacher get killed and one of the things
that i
i think when i watch something like that
is surely everyone's overcome with
emotion and thinks we have to act we
have to implement at least some common
sense gun reform we can talk also about
mental health and all those things but
step one common sense gun reform
universal background checks red flag
laws waiting periods
raising the age
for when you can get guns right
well as you all know
that's not the way that everyone
responds to these tragedies
unfortunately unfortunately a lot of
people
republican politicians specifically see
their whole job
when a tragedy like this happens as
standing in the way of anything from
being done
at least on the issue of guns nothing
can happen
in regard to gun control after these
tragedies and that's what they see their
job as
and
they kind of offer up vague solutions as
i kind of allude to earlier oh it's
mental health always school security but
they don't propose specific solutions
and then their primary focus is
distracting from the big blinking red
led sign which is gun control
and louis gomer did this exactly on the
house floor recently
saying that guys
saying that the reason
maybe the reason that mass shootings
have gone up is because kids don't pray
in school anymore
we were told in debate last week don't
want to hear any more about social media
violent video games hollywood mental
illness and they sure don't want to hear
any more about prayers they're disgusted
hearing about prayers don't want to hear
any more about fatherlessness drug use
look maybe if we heard more prayers from
leaders of this country instead of
taking god's name in vain
we wouldn't have the mass killings like
we didn't have before
prayer was eliminated from school
what do you say to that i know this is
such a cliche
thing but
louie how do you sleep with yourself
honestly i know that someone like louis
gomer is completely aware that
implementing common sense gun reform
that would not be infringing on anyone's
second amendment right
would save lives it would save countless
lives
but for some reason whether it's
appealing to a radical part of its base
keeping those nra funds flowing i don't
know what his reason is but for some
reason
he would rather stand in the way of
doing any of that
and he would rather say oh maybe it's
because kids don't pray in school really
imagine staring in the face of all of
the evidence
that shows the reason why america stands
so much apart or set so much apart from
all these other countries and the level
of gun violence we have is because we
don't have
uh common sense gun laws imagine looking
at all that evidence and going i don't
care
i would rather
not just ignore the evidence but
actively work against
anyone from
acting in a logical manner based on that
evidence
to prevent tragedies from happening
in this country i
honestly that clip looks like someone
doing a parody of a
anti-gun reform uh republican politician
like that's not even real
oh no it's not gun it's not the lack of
gun reform or the lack of common sense
gun laws it's kids not doing their
morning prayer in class
you don't believe that no way anyone
would believe that
and i'm so down again like i'll say this
a thousand times
whenever these conversations come up
let's invest in mental health let's try
to promote happy healthy supporting
families
let's secure our schools
but then let's also
implement common sense gun reform it's
just not that hard
but he makes it hard people like him
make it hard and they try to distract
and even as ludicrous ways is saying oh
it's morning prayers that have gone away
that caused these mass shootings in
schools one of our sponsors is magic
spoon the only breakfast cereal that
tastes exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto you
can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description